[Music]
time now for final exam where he pit two
hardened news professionals against one
another in a gladiator style match to
see who's been paying more attention at
work this week last week you'll remember
that America's News headquarters host
Leland vetted ended shannon bream is
legendary nine match winning streak
can he start streak of his own tonight
that's the question challenger fox news
headlines 24/7 reporter carly shem
kissed the pride of new york city they
join us both tonight on set not even
close to nerve are you ready I love it
okay feeling confident are you do you
know the rules let's refresh their hands
on buzzers I'm gonna ask the questions
the first one to buzz in gets to answer
the question after wait till I finish
asking the question before you buzz in
each correct answer is worth the point
if you get it wrong you lose a point
best of five wins are you probably ready
yes okay good question one North and
South Korea will join forces in the
Winter Olympics next month the two
countries have agreed to come together
to create a single team for which
women's sport Carly figure skating
figure skating to the tape we go will be
a very rare sight during next month's
Winter Olympics North and South Korea
agreeing to form a joint team and March
under one flag they'll play together two
in the United women's ice hockey team
sore judges have ruled the just because
it's on ice skates it's not the same I
think it should you think we should do a
half point charge here we've got a
roomful of accountants yes we could you
know fortunately we can't count that
Alright nice try it thank you question
two you're about to see an image of a
car dangling off the second floor of a
dental office crazy dashcam footage of
that incident went viral on the internet
this week the question is how the car
get there Carly okay a little bit of a
backstory the guy was arrested he
received a DUI he flew over the media
and because of the trajectory ended up
in the second story of that dental
office wow that's quite a let's let's if
the tape reflects that to the tape this
happened in Santa Ana look at that they
hit that medium and then the car as you
saw when airborne and it landed right
into the second floor of a dental office
the car there you see it dangling right
off that building and he walked away
yeah well everybody there was nobody in
the dental office I believe and he was
of course arrested but he's okay minor
injuries he's got a party story okay so
you are back to even it stays a status
quo par zero to zero left question three
that's good to know a medical briefing a
televised one for 58 minutes revealed
this week that the president is indeed
healthy but that didn't stop reporters
from fat-shaming him when NBC producer
asked Trump to prove his weight with a
very strange request
what was it Carly step on a scale I
don't believe that let's see to the tape
a member of NBC's investigative unit
tweeted out this Jem seeing a lot of
skepticism over the idea that real
Donald Trump weighs only 239 pounds when
you step on a scale and public to prove
it yeah he'll do that when reporters and
anchors agree to public lie detector
test during their broadcast or after
their broadcast okay step on a scale I
would not have guessed that question for
the temperature rises on the set Google
which is a large search engine company
just released a new app it has become
popular the app takes your selfie a
picture of you and compares it to what
portraits yeah so museum famous museum
pictures paintings and portraits
fountain museums that's bizarre
does the tape reflect portraits famous
portraits in music image could already
resemble a work of art on the walls of a
museum somewhere this is located in the
arm of Museum in Indonesia and it is a
famous very famous ok ambulance I like
it not even strong this is such BS I did
mine on my own and this is what I came
up with sad you're so lonely in needy
that you're gonna let Google use your
face you know I knew that because I
actually did it this week and the
portrait I received that resembled me
the most I got a 60% match with that of
a bald man well let's see I think
actually we did it to what we came up
with did Leland this is the poet Robert
Burns Wow did they do you Tucker that's
what I'm watching I'm not aware of that
yes he does have very nice hair so you
guys I think they just took our like Fox
ID back last question Wow it's multiple
choice actress and comedian Betty White
had a birthday yesterday she credits her
longevity to her love of hotdogs and
vodka naturally yeah how old is Betty
White 1886 be is she 90 where see is she
96 years old she is 86 years old she's
86 years old says Carly to the tape we
go very very happy birthday for a very
golden girl Betty White everybody
[Applause]
did I get that right she's 96 off by 10
years prevent you from winning 1-0 it's
the lowest score ever recorded but still
an impressive showing patience very nice
I will say to you what Shannon said to
me in the green room a couple of minutes
ago she said you only have eight more
championships to win before she will
come back challenge rising like Lazarus
okay so you win the coveted
mouth-breather bug is that really yes
popular person in the break room
congratulations Karly sugar are you
right I get a mug dishwasher safe God
thank you Leland thank you you were a
giant killer
history will record that too